tobin congratulations you've made it to
the third and final level of this
competition and now we're going to let
you choose which one of our remaining
judges you're going to compete against
either two-time forest and fire champion
ben abbott
or historic weapons recreation
specialist david baker who's it gonna be
i'm gonna go with the baker
all right then
he's the baker and he rocks a vest
hey buddy
[Laughter]
david baker is stiff competition and
choosing david because i know it's going
to be a tough challenge
i'm competing for the breast cancer
research fund breast cancer is something
that's touched my life in a number of
different ways i know how devastating it
can be so the more research we can put
towards this the better we're gonna be
in this third and final level of
competition we're gonna ask you guys to
use
these
to make your blades
those are stacks of 15 and 20 and 1095
steel you will have to use those to make
a layer damascus billet from which you
will forge your blades now
we're not going to stop with the choices
right there you also have the
opportunity to use those stacked billets
to make one of these
your choice of either a spadru
an ida or a chorus sword tobin you get
to pick your poison in this round this
will be the blade that both of you will
have to make
the thing about the chorus sword is it
is a very wide and heavy sword and i'm
not gonna wrestle a sword like that
without wasting time the spadrone has
fittings that i've seen david baker make
before so i kind of want to keep as much
advantage to myself as possible the
thing about the ida is it tapers towards
the handle instead of tapering towards
the tip and
that's actually complex it's not an easy
choice the ida
the ida
the ite is a deceptive weapon it looks
very simple
it's not you've got an integral guard
you've got a blade that has a large
medial ridge that's a tough challenge
gentlemen you have eight hours to
complete this weapon in totality good
luck gentlemen your eight hour starts
now
we have both 15 and 20 and 10.95 i cut
each one into four inch sections i use
18 pieces in alternation
my plan is to draw this out and cut it
into four pieces and restack i'm at 72
layers why is it important to have
so many layers in damascus that makes
the pattern pop a lot more as soon as
that goes in the forge i grab handle
material and i start cutting my
hand
so how is it being on this side
you know what i love it i just love
building i don't know any chance i get
to make stuff i'm there
get steel out give it a couple of quick
little passes and everything looks nice
and welding i'm hoping i can stretch it
out fold it stack 42.
the first time i can't forget the fire
was just to have fun i didn't expect
much
a cutlass
army hearties we get to make a cutlass
i'm very excited about that
if i'm able to win then it's going to
prove to myself that i'm doing the right
thing right now i get distracted by dave
because he's doing such awesome work i'm
like oh i want to watch but yeah i got
to focus on doing my stuff
tom's a very talented smith i want to
see him succeed i want to see him do
everything but win
in a nice way you know
blade smith's four hours has a lapse
that is half the time in this level of
competition super duper
all right so dave's in a quench
a nice color to that yeah
yeah baby now my blade's pretty good it
looks really straight maybe just a small
warp towards the tang i put it in the
vise straighten it that's what we're
talking
i'm about about that
sounds hard
i'm getting the bevels forged in and
then at that moment my fingers
in my left hand they're starting to go
numb
where's medic oh boy dope is in trouble
i'm starting to feel this numbness creep
through my shoulder all the way down to
my hand you ready just take deep breaths
for me okay my blood pressure is up my
heart rate's up just trying to calm down
i'm not even worried about what dave is
doing i got to take care of myself your
arm feel better uh it's it's gone i mean
the kingdoms died everything feels okay
it's time to get back to work good
right
all right
i'm not gonna quit i'm just gonna keep
doing what i can with the time that i
got just go from there i got my blade
shaped out time to work on my tang
so tobin's tang is stretching out pretty
good
it's ready to go into the oil four hours
into this competition i wasn't sure that
tobo was gonna walk across the finish
line you got to give him a huge amount
of props for being where he is right now
i need to have a mechanical lock so i
drilled through the wood threw up in my
tang
i'm trying to get my pin in it doesn't
want to go in come on
i finally get the pin in but now i
needed to come out because i forgot to
put epoxy inside
really
it's jammed in there i can't get it out
now and then as i'm trying to pull the
pin out
oh the pin just broke
this is bad because the only thing
holding my handle to the blade right now
is half of a brass pin come on kid kick
it into gear
i can punch this out later i got to go
grind i got to get the handle shape
i'm gonna turn in something no matter
what five
four
three
two
one
white smith stop what you're doing this
level of competition is over hey come
here brother
oh
oh man it's an ass kick right now that
was fun
today i feel like i did really good for
myself i didn't stop and i wasn't gonna
stop until i heard time's up
all right bladesmiths this is the kill
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i'm gonna take your
weapon deliver some lethal slashes and
cuts on this ballistics dummy dave
you're first you ready sir oh yeah let's
do this
i'm a little worried i don't think it
matters who you are when you're in
competition you know you could think you
nailed it then you're there standing in
front of your judges and you're like
anything could happen
huh
see ya
that's nasty
all right dave let's talk about your
weapon here the pattern you have here is
beautiful your handle construction
is clean
i can wrap my hand around it and when
you swing with this it's balanced enough
to where it's a chopper and a slicer
your edge
is sharp
it chops and cleans cleanly overall sir
it will kill thank you doug
tobin you're up next ready
we're gonna do it anyways okay sounds
good
good luck brother
i know my blade is light i know it's
fast
but i also know that i made my handle
very quickly and it's not my best work
so it's in the judge's hands now
looks like he's gonna go
it's breaking i can feel it cracking
gentlemen
take a look at this
hear all that movement
nothing else i'm trying to do i can
swing it it wants to pop out now the pin
doesn't go all the way through the pin
is only going through one side okay i
just see the judges whispering and
holding the handle and shaking the blade
yeah i don't think it looks good right
now
do you have confidence in this weapon to
test i do not
absolutely not no no all right let's
let's let him know
tobin you put in a lot of work but i
think you know what's coming down the
pipe the judges have given your weapon a
vote of no confidence doug markite is
going to tell you why
tobin a lot of props for you for pushing
through eight hours going through the
health issues and everything else you
did a good job of finishing your blade
but your handle construction is loose
even just by moving it in the air i can
feel it already loosening up and you can
hear some slight cracking on the handle
to swing that with impact definitely
it's going to be a failure and safety is
always first yep
tobin unfortunately your blade is unsafe
the test that means that you cannot win
this competition and dave you win you
win the ten thousand dollars that's
going to the charity of your choice and
what charity is that my friend that's
the breast cancer research fund
all right man that sounds fantastic come
on for you guys
i agree 100 with the judge's decision
and i'm not disappointed at all
a lot of hard work
i came here because i had to test myself
to see if this is the right way i was
going and the fact that i didn't quit
that i persevered and pushed on to the
very end tells me that being a
bladesmith is what i want to do
you know tobin is a great smith he had a
bit of a health issue but he came back
from that he kept fighting through i
have a feeling if he hadn't lost that
time we would have been testing two
blades
[Music]
you